jusqu'à ce qu'elles fassent le tour complet de la salle, et il a dit,
« Ok, tout le monde, accrochez-vous à vos pailles. »
Et nous l'avons fait. Il a dit, « Bien. Maintenant nous sommes tous connectés. »
Et alors que nous les tenions, et respirions à l’unisson,
nous savions que nous n’étions pas seul dans cette épreuve.
Et même allongés et paralysés dans cette salle,
il y a eu des moments d'une profondeur et d'une richesse incroyables,
d'authenticité et de connexion
que je n’avais jamais expérimenté auparavant.
Et chacun d’entre nous savait qu’en quittant cette chambre
nous ne serions plus jamais les mêmes.
Après 6 mois, il était temps de rentrer à la maison.
Je me souviens de papa me poussant dans le fauteuil roulant,
le corps entièrement plâtré,
je sentais les rayons du soleil sur mon visage pour la première fois.
J’ai pris un bain de soleil, et j’ai pensé,
comment ai-je pu prendre ça pour acquis ?
Je me sentais incroyablement reconnaissante pour ma vie.
Mais avant de quitter l’hôpital, l’infirmière en chef
m’a dit, « Janine, je veux que vous vous prépariez,
parce que quand vous serez à la maison, quelque chose va arriver. »
Et j’ai dit, « Quoi ? ». Elle répondit
« Vous allez déprimer. »
J’ai répondu, « Pas moi, pas Janine-la-machine »,
c’était mon surnom.
Elle a dit, « Ça va arriver, parce que, comme vous le voyez, ça arrive à tout le monde.
Dans cette salle, c'est normal.
Tu es dans une chaise roulante et c'est normal.
Mais, tu vas rentrer chez toi et te rendre compte
à quel point la vie est différente. »
Je suis rentrée à la maison et c’est arrivé.
J’ai réalisé que Sœur Sam avait raison.
J’étais déprimée.
J’étais dans mon fauteuil roulant. Je ne sentais rien en-dessous de la taille,
j’étais attaché à la perfusion. Je ne pouvais pas marcher.
J’avais perdu tellement de poids à l’hôpital,
je pesais désormais 40 kilos.
J'avais envie d'abandonner.
Tout ce que je voulais, c’était mettre mes baskets et aller courir.
Je voulais retrouver mon ancienne vie. Je voulais retrouver mon corps.
Et je me souviens de Maman assise au bout de mon lit,
me disant, « Je me demande si la vie sera de nouveau belle un jour. »
Et j’ai pensé, « Comment ça pourrait ? Parce que j’ai tout perdu,
tout ce pour quoi j’avais travaillé.
C’était terminé. »
Et je me suis demandé, « Pourquoi moi ? Pourquoi moi ? ».
Et je me suis souvenu de mes amis
qui étaient toujours dans cette salle,
en particulier Maria.
Maria a eu un accident de voiture, elle s’est réveillée
le jour de son 16ème anniversaire et a appris qu’elle était tétraplégique,
qu’elle ne pouvait pas bouger quoi que ce soit en dessous du cou,
ses cordes vocales étaient endommagées, et elle ne pouvait pas parler.
Ils m’avaient dit, « On va te mettre à côté d’elle
car on pense que ce serait bien pour elle. »
J'étais inquiète. Je ne savais pas comment j'allais réagir
au fait d'être à côté d'elle.
Je savais que ça serait un défi, mais c'était en fait une bénédiction,
parce que Maria souriait toujours.
Elle était toujours heureuse, et même quand elle a pu recommencer à parler,
bien que c’était difficile à comprendre, elle ne se plaignait jamais, pas une fois.
Et je me demandais comment elle avait accepté cela.
J’ai réalisé que ce n’était pas que ma vie.
C’était la vie elle-même. J’ai compris que ce n’était pas que ma douleur.
C'était la douleur de tout le monde. Et j'ai su que, comme avant,
j'avais le choix. Je pouvais continuer à me battre contre le sort
ou je pouvais laisser aller et accepter non seulement mon corps
mais également ma situation.
J’ai arrêté de me demander « Pourquoi moi ? »
et j’ai commencé à me demander « Pourquoi pas moi ? »
Alors je me suis dit, peut-être que le fond du trou
est en fait le meilleur point de départ.
Je ne m'étais jamais considérée comme quelqu'un de créatif.
J'étais une athlète. Mon corps était une machine.
Mais j’étais maintenant sur le point de commencer le projet le plus créatif
qu’on puisse imaginer :
reconstruire une vie.
Et même si je n’avais absolument aucune idée
de ce que j’allais faire, cette incertitude
m'a donné une sensation de liberté.
Je n’étais plus lié à un chemin déjà tracé.
J’étais libre d’explorer les infinies possibilités de la vie.
Et cette prise de conscience était sur le point de changer ma vie.
A la maison, assise dans mon fauteuil et le corps dans le plâtre,
un avion est passé dans le ciel, je l'ai regardé
et je me suis dit, « C’est ça !
Si je ne peux pas marcher, je pourrais voler. »
J'ai dit, « Maman, je vais apprendre à voler. »
Elle a répondu : « Bien sûr chérie, bien sûr ». (Rires)
Je lui ai dit : « Passe moi les pages jaunes ».
Elle m'a passé le bottin, et j'ai appelé l'école d'aviation,
J'ai pris rendez-vous pour un vol.
Ils m'ont dit : « Vous savez quand vous voulez venir ? »
J'ai répondu : « Et bien il va falloir que je trouve quelqu'un pour m'amener
parce que je ne peux pas conduire. Je peux pas vraiment marcher non plus.
Est-ce que ça pose problème ? »
J'ai pris mon rendez-vous et quelques semaines plus tard, mon ami Chris
et ma mère m'ont conduite à l'aéroport,
mes 40 kilos recouvert de plâtre
dans une salopette large. (Rires)
Je peux vous dire que je ne ressemblait pas à la candidate idéale
pour obtenir un brevet de pilote. (Rires)
Je me tenais au comptoir pour pouvoir me tenir debout.
J'ai dit : « Bonjour, je suis là pour un cours de pilotage. »
Ils m'ont regardée et sont allés à l'arrière pour tirer à la courte paille.
« Tu la prends. » « Non, non, toi, tu la prends. »
Finalement, ce gars sort et me dit
« Salut, je suis Andrew, et je vais vous emmener voler. »
J'ai répondu « Génial. » Ils m'ont emmené
sur le tarmac,
où il y avait cet avion rouge, blanc et bleu.
Il était magnifique. Ils m'ont portée dans le cockpit.
Ils ont dû me faire glisser sur une aile pour me mettre dedans
Ils m'ont assise. Il y avait des boutons et des touches partout.
J'ai dit, « Waw, comment savez-vous à quoi servent tous ces boutons et ces touches ? »
Andrew, l'instructeur, s'est assis à l'avant et a fait démarrer l'avion.
Il a dit, « Est-ce que vous voulez essayer le roulage ? »
C'est quand vous utilisez vos pieds pour contrôler le palonnier
pour diriger l'avion au sol.
J'ai répondu, « Non, je ne peux pas utiliser mes jambes. »
Il répond « Oh. »
J'ai dit, « Mais je peux utiliser mes mains », et il a répondu, « Ok. »
Donc il a pris la piste et a mis les gaz.
Alors qu'on décollait de la piste,
les roues quittaient le tarmac, nous étions en vol,
j'ai eu le plus incroyable sentiment de liberté.
Andrew m'a dit,
alors qu'on survolait la zone d'entrainement
« Tu vois ces montagnes là-haut ? »
Et j'ai dit, « Oui ».
Il m'a répondu, « Et bien, tu prends les commandes, et tu voles vers cette montagne. »
J'ai levé les yeux et je me suis rendue compte
qu'il pointait son doigt vers les Blue Mountains
où ce parcours avait commencé.
Alors j'ai pris les commandes, et j'ai volé.
J'étais loin, bien loin de cette salle d'hôpital
et à cet instant même, je savais que j'allais être pilote.
Je n'avais aucune idée de la façon dont j'allais passer les tests médicaux.
Mais je m'en inquiéterais plus tard, car là maintenant, j'avais un rêve.
Donc je suis rentrée à la maison, j'avais un carnet d'entraînement et j'avais un plan.
Je me suis entrainée à marcher autant que possible,
et je suis passé du point où deux personnes me tenaient,
à une personne,
jusqu'au moment où je pouvais marcher de meuble en meuble
tant qu'ils n'étaient pas trop éloignés.
Ensuite, j'ai fait de gros progrès, au point
où je pouvais marcher dans la maison, en me tenant aux murs,
comme ceci, et ma mère disait qu'elle passait son temps à me suivre
pour nettoyer mes traces de doigts. (Rires).
Mais au moins, elle savait toujours où j'étais.
Alors pendant que les médecins continuaient à m'opérer,
et remettre mon corps d'aplomb,
j'étudiais la théorie, et finalement,
j'ai miraculeusement passé l'examen médical,
j'avais le feu vert pour voler.
J'ai passé autant de temps que possible dans cette l'école d'aviation,
bien loin de ma zone de confort,
tous ces jeunes gens qui voulaient devenir pilote pour Qantas,
vous voyez, et moi la petit claudicante dans mon plâtre au début
et ensuite avec mes prothèses, la large salopette,
mon sac de médicaments et de cathéters, mon boitillement,
ils avaient l'habitude de me regarder et de penser,
« Oh, de qui se moque-t-elle ? Elle n'en sera jamais capable. »
Et parfois, je partageais leur avis.
Mais ça n'avait pas d'importance, j'avais maintenant un feu intérieur
bien plus important que mes blessures.
Les petits objectifs m'ont gardé sur la voie
et finalement j'ai eu mon brevet de pilote,
ensuite j'ai appris à piloter et j'ai emmené mes amis à travers l'Australie.
Ensuite j'ai appris à voler sur un bimoteur
et j'ai été qualifiée pour les bimoteurs.
Ensuite j'ai appris à voler par mauvais temps aussi bien que par beau temps
et j'ai eu ma qualification au vol aux instruments
Ensuite j'ai eu mon brevet de pilote professionnel.
Ensuite j'ai eu ma qualification d'instructeur.
Et je me suis retrouvée de retour dans la même école
où j'avais fait mon premier vol,
à enseigner aux autres personnes à voler,
moins de 18 mois après avoir quitté cette salle d'hôpital.
(Applaudissements)
Et j'ai pensé, « Pourquoi en rester là ?
Pourquoi ne pas apprendre à voler la tête en bas ? »
Je l'ai fait, j'ai appris à voler la tête en bas
et je suis devenue instructeur de voltige.
Et maman et papa ? Jamais montés.
Mais ensuite, j'ai su, avec certitude, que bien que mon corps puisse être limité,
c'était mon esprit qui était inarrêtable.
Le philosophe Lao Tseu a dit un jour,
« Quand tu abandonnes ce que tu es,
tu deviens ce que tu peux être. »
Je sais maintenant que ce n'est que lorsque j'ai abandonné l'idée de qui je pensais être
que j'ai été capable de construire une vie complètement nouvelle.
Ce n'est que lorsque j'ai abandonné la vie que je pensais avoir
que j'ai été capable d'accepter la vie qui m'attendait.
Je sais maintenant que ma vraie force
n'est jamais venue de mon corps,
bien que mes capacités physiques aient considérablement changé,
je n'ai pas changé.
La veilleuse à l'intérieur de moi a toujours été une lumière,
comme elle l'est en chacun d'entre nous.
Je sais que je ne suis pas mon corps,
et je sais aussi que vous n’êtes pas le vôtre.
Ça n’a aucune importance à quoi vous ressemblez,
d’où vous venez, ou comment vous gagnez votre vie.
Tout ce qui importe c’est de continuer à attiser la flamme d'humanité
en vivant nos vies comme l'expression créative ultime
de ce que nous sommes vraiment,
parce que nous sommes tous liés
par des millions et des millions de pailles,
il est temps de les relier
et de s'accrocher.
Et si nous voulons avancer vers notre bonheur collectif,
il est temps de se délester de notre attention sur le physique
et à la place, d'adopter les vertus du cœur.
Alors levez vos pailles si vous voulez me rejoindre.
Merci. (Applaudissements).
Merci.